I think we're talking about a team that
has the best chance of representing the
Eastern Conference I went through some
some difficulties last year losing to
Toronto he has to prove to you that he
has learned from that failure in those
final four games against Toronto we
build a winning culture on the team and
everybody know what we got to do when we
step on the float we gotta go out there
and put our I sit in the position to win
but offensively with the Bucks are doing
something different so this is this is a
significant margin but bucks
keep on when and why will you gotta book
the finger to the reigning MVP when you
see some Yanis this year as an MVP
candidate to see the maturation and the
growth physically in his game and
everywhere his pun believable
giannis is putting the better stats than
he did last year how good can this team
you are we for real talk about
championship contender and that core is
just it's it's almost like they become a
tiger team in the clothes routine
they're ready to play every single
quietly Middleton's
is quietly having Japanese almost 50 40
and 90 the reigning MVP honors on
typical ball a 50 point 9
hi and a resounding victory over
the Western Conference
but that was an impressive win for them
and that kind of put them like think
around the league around the world I go
this is a top team not just in the East
but a talk to him luigi's be worried
about Milwaukee right now is having an
unbelievable stardom they got to be
picked not for spinal Dodger so really
the only thing that's ahead of them is
that you've gotta get to the finals and
you've got to win the last decade has
been a struggle for for Lakers fans you
know like there hasn't been a ton of
success we know that we have a great
team and all we can ask for is a chance
and we have a chance to do something
special this year
now put on that language or automatic
magic Kobe Shaq as soon as I put that on
I get a sense of pride like alright but
you better hold Joanne to the bargain up
[Applause]
I'm watching him them live like wow he's
enjoying himself
continue to show why they're considered
a perfect one-two combo
[Applause]
defensively I want to share one down
because a player dear any show tonight
once again
did you what do you want to be the
different this time all right
I just so just wanna win yeah that's the
only thing that matters is being the
best teammate and the best the white
Howard I
[Applause]
when abroad has a chance to go would say
hello to Toby who is sitting in the
front row right at midcourt his little
bronze still the best player in the NBA
who's in the discussion it's really down
to
I think Milwaukee's going to coast to
the NBA Finals
between these two guys best team and
Association makers of bus both of my
planner at a high rate
bucks right there with the legroom
walking
these the Lakers holding
for wet
[Music]